We Begin this NewsHour with breaking
news from russian-controlled Crimea
Moscow says Ukrainian missiles have
targeted its Black Sea Fleet
headquarters in the peninsula it said
Russian air defense systems shot down
five missiles during the attack in
savastapol but black smoke has been seen
billowing from the base crimea's
russian-backed Governor has urged
civilians to remain indoors and stay
away from the city center until further
notice in recent weeks Ukraine has
stepped up its attacks on Russia's Navy
journalist Julia shapovalova is standing
by in Moscow for us first though let's
talk to Zane vasravi in the Ukrainian
Capital Zane what are you learning about
this
yeah
well obviously we're getting very
differing reports from Russian and
Ukrainian sources but here on the ground
in Kiev leaders military and civilian
alike we'll be celebrating what they
consider no doubt to be a successful
mission on the Crimean Peninsula we've
heard attacks of multiple missile
attacks on Targets in the peninsula
multiple explosions in the last few
hours and the prime target seems to be
the headquarters of the Black Sea Fleet
now the Black Sea fleet has been the
main military thrust of Russia's in this
war in Ukraine since the invasion began
and this will no doubt come as a major
uh major problem for Russian forces here
what we're hearing is other locations
were also hit for other locations on the
peninsula but it seems to be that the
headquarters of the Black Sea fleet was
a primary target now we've heard
unconfirmed reports of casualties there
being in the double digits and it comes
after a week or two of some very high
profile missions taken out a taken by
the ukrainians just over a week ago they
destroyed a submarine and a warship in a
Sebastopol Dry Dock they also took back
the boyca towers in the in the Black Sea
an important location from which Russia
operated logistics for its military
operations in the area and we also heard
reports in the last week that Russian
air defenses in Crimea had been taken
out seemingly in preparation for this
very high profile attack now though
Ukrainian forces will be seeing this as
a success there is some concern that
this could lead to retaliatory attacks
on Kiev and other cities no doubt people
are on high alert here however that is
not dampening Spirits it seems the
ukrainians are putting out some
liberatory messages on social media
saying it will get worse for the
Russians on the occupied Crimean
Peninsula and a note from the National
Security council's Alexi denalov let me
just read to you a recent statement by
him this sort of gives a sense of what
more is to come he said there are two
options for the future of Russia's Black
Sea Fleet voluntary or forced
self-neutralization so that gives you a
sense of how seriously Ukrainian forces
are pursuing trying to if not
immediately take back the peninsula
which has been this day to go for some
time at the very least make it very
difficult for Russian Physicians to
remain there Zane thank you very much I
want to get the Russian perspective on
this let's go to Julia shop of Oliver
Yulia you're in Moscow Russia's Fleet in
the Black Sea a major military asset
what is Russia saying about this
well absolutely faster getting reports
from the Russian Ministry of defense and
according to them uh five missiles had
been shot down uh one serviceman was
killed and five more injured so what we
see indicates that the Russian Ukrainian
armed conflict is Raging on and this
time around Russia's Fleet Russia's
precious asset as you said has been
targeted so according to the governor of
sevastopol the civilian infrastructure
around the fleet headquarters which are
located in the very center of the city
was not actually damaged and the people
who were on this street at the time of
the track were also unheard the police
had codoned off the central part of this
city where the debris had scattered
around an area of 200 meters the
building itself suffered significant
damage as well and uh also a fire
started there right out of that tiger
firefighters are still putting it out
residents have been asked not to trap
level to the center and according to
preliminary reports the air defense
missiles
well the air defenses actually missed
two missiles and shot down eight but
presumably there were British cruise
missiles of This Storm Shadow type or
similar French ones but that information
has to be verified
Julia sharp of Oliver in Moscow thank
you very much Julia